summer is coming to a close
but before we welcome fall e.t is taking
a look at the best bikini-clad stars of
summer 2017. how hot is it going to get
sir temperature wise
[Music]
demi lovato turned up the heat this year
soaking up the sun in several
eye-popping swimsuits during her
tropical getaways
emily ratajowski totally embodied what
it means to be a bikini babe bearing it
all near the sand shore and even a
luxury yacht then there's 52 year old
elizabeth hurley who put her toned body
on display proving age is well
just a number right thanks cindy the
supermodel also lounged around looking
lean and serene
and sports illustrated ashley graham
slayed us with her curves oh i love my
hourglass figure i like to show it off
meanwhile leah michelle appeared to have
the time of her life in hawaii she
actually said she never wants this
vacation to end i've had the greatest
times the actress flashed her fit figure
while getting her zen on for a paddle
board yoga session
then there's gabrielle union who gave us
not only couple goals with hubby dwayne
wade in greece but also body goals she
rocked this bright pink bikini and
braids
you know she looked relaxed but she's
still sexy i like it of course what
would a bikini run down be without a few
kardashian jenners sizzling in the sun
from a bronze kylie jenner to sister
kourtney kardashian who practically
lived in a two-piece while traveling the
bikini queen took her followers around
the world courtney has three kids she's
never looked better she's like the
hottest mom ever speaking of hot moms 61
year old kris jenner put her curves on
display in this mirror selfie daughter
chloe captioned looking like a snack
hashtag six kids and bad
other fit moms turning heads jlo who
showed off her toned cheeks in a thong
bikini
heidi klum made a splash with her crew
and went topless in st bart's then
there's halle berry she channeled a
golden goddess in this snap quote
all gold hashtag no spray tan that's
what i do and then there's a bikini clad
hilary duff topping our roundup after
clapping back at body shamers she wrote
my body has given me the greatest gift
of my life luca five years ago
adding let's be proud of what we've got
and stop wasting precious time in the
day wishing we were different better and
my eyes and unflawed will take whatever
[Music]